as of tonight there are thousands of u.s
citizens americans trapped in
afghanistan they can't get to the
airport in kabul because the roads
to the airport are controlled by the
taliban
now the us government allowed that to
happen joe biden is on vacation so he
can't explain how he allowed that to
happen but today the white house press
secretary said right out loud that the
buy administration will not guarantee
the evacuation of americans stranded in
afghanistan
sorry
can you
offer any guarantee to the americans and
afghan allies that if they remain there
past the end of the month u.s troops
will help them evacuate we'll pass the
end of the month we are our focus right
now is uh undoing the work at hand and
on the task at hand and that is day by
day getting as many american citizens as
many siv applicants as many members of a
vulnerable population who are eligible
to be evacuated to the airport and out
on planes
notice how she puts all three together
americans
special visa applicants vulnerable
popular what the hell is that
you know who's vulnerable as americans
who are trapped in afghanistan right now
they're american citizens the american
government exist to help american
citizens not to help vulnerable
populations whatever that is that's the
definition that changes depending on
which interest group is in power no it's
americans that's the point of the
american government
but nobody cares
our leaders are telling us that what
really matters is importing tens of
thousands of afghan refugees into the
united states before we've even
evacuated all of the americans who are
stuck there
now keep in mind these aren't just
translators that they want to import
people who've loyally served the us
military or whatever it's anybody in
afghanistan who wants to come here for
the free healthcare
who's in favor of this well on the
record 46 u.s senators 43 democrats and
three republicans just called on the
biden administration to quote create a
humanitarian parole category for quote
afghan women leaders activists judges
and other public figures to quickly and
efficiently relocate to the united
states
brian kemp
the kind of pathetic governor of georgia
he's a republican apparently just
announced he wants afghan refugee camps
in his state okay so of course the media
is completely in favor of this they hate
the population of the united states cnn
is accusing anyone who doesn't want this
of being a racist
though by the way
have you seen the people live in
afghanistan a lot of them are whiter
than i am it's nothing with race
it has to do with putting american
citizens first
period
but they don't get that it's not even a
category that makes sense to them
politico this morning write a symposium
on how we can help afghanistan as if we
owe afghanistan a lot we've helped
afghanistan a lot
not simply by spending more than a
trillion dollars where that money go
but also by letting an awful lot of
afghans move here more than a hundred
thousand special visas
to residents of afghanistan and iraq in
the past couple of decades we've issued
a total of three 000 green cards to
residents of those two countries now
we're told that's not enough we're just
hard-hearted or something we don't take
enough immigrants
this country is getting so volatile and
divided
maybe we have a moratorium on any new
people coming in we can sort out our own
problems till we can learn to get along
with each other and after we have
brought all of our americans home
americans home sean parnell is running
for senate in the state of pennsylvania
he was infantry platoon leader during
the war in afghanistan he worked with an
afghan interpreter for more than a year
before that interpreter helped
terrorists plan an ied that killed one
of his men it's a complex subject he
knows it very well and we're happy to
have him on with us tonight sean thanks
so much for coming on
look this idea that
vulnerable populations whatever the hell
that means should
get pride of place are more important
than american citizens trapped in
afghanistan i don't think i've ever seen
anything that reveals their priorities
more clearly
yeah first of all thanks for having me
tucker and if you want to help save this
country go to parnell for senate.com um
so so look
we should not have a single conversation
about what happens with refugees in
afghanistan until we evacuate american
citizens first that should be our number
one priority um the situation is urgent
and we have to get our people out of
there before the taliban takes us
hostage look
tucker i was in afghanistan for 485 days
uh 85 casualty rate in my platoon some
of my men were wounded twice uh we
worked with an afghan interpreter for
for over a year he was on every mission
with us he was on every fight with us
and one day we got tasked with an
observation post to watch info routes
from pakistan into afghanistan uh my
platoon that day rolled up onto the hill
we wondered why the afghan villagers all
around that hilltop were watching were
watching the platoon
rolled up onto the hill
one of my trucks hit a plastic italian
tc6 anti-tank mine it wounded four of my
soldiers seriously and killed somebody
in my platoon
after that mission was over during our
after action report
um we found out that our interpreter who
had been with us every step of the way
someone who we thought was our friend
we learned that he was working with an
iranian ied cell in pakistan and
coordinated the placement of that mine
which killed one of my troops in a
devastating attack
tucker
just because
somebody just just because an afghan
works with us
and is friends with us does not does not
actually mean they're safe to bring here
and this is precisely why
we cannot bring 30 000 unvetted afghan
refugees to the united states of america
it's an irresponsible policy and
quite frankly i can't believe we even
have to have this conversation american
citizens have to have the priority they
have they have to they have to be the
priority
they're not though and something happens
in the brains particularly these
middle-aged republican leaders their
brains go soft
low testosterone may be part of the
cause and they decide
that they you know every dumb idea they
have to kind of cringe and oh that's
okay
you know what i mean the governor of
arkansas is like this the governor of
georgia like what is wrong with these
people why don't you stand up for
american citizens it's not hard
what what i can't wrap my mind around
tucker is that we have talking heads
media personalities and politicians
trotting out 20-year-old foreign policy
arguments the idea that we have to fight
them there to keep from fighting
fighting us here what happens in
afghanistan doesn't stay in afghanistan
tucker these are not foreign policy
arguments
these are arguments for wars and
countries at any time in any place for
an indeterminate amount of time think
about it what happens in africa what
happens in africa
it doesn't stay in africa what happens
in iraq doesn't stay in iraq so i'm
tired of these these arguments our
politicians our leaders have to be more
careful with america's sons and
daughters they're the best of us and we
need to take care of them
amen there's an ocean separating us from
the rest of the world let's use it
john parnell i appreciate you coming on
tonight thank you
thanks tucker hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else